all right okay you later vote you good I
think so
Peter protect the Guardians Donnell
separated their souls from their bodies
they're out too long they will die I
don't know how to fix that no I know you
don't but she does okay stay here
[Music]
wait
wake up stupid hey it's not working well
you can do this you can do it the wizard
says you could do it
I can't they're dying you have to
oh you may hit a couple things on the
way down not actually my fault you're
just super heavy welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is gonna be my
breakdown of the New Avengers infinity
saga deleted scene of spider-man and
mantis and Doctor Strange saving
everyone's souls so it gets super cosmic
super weird there's a lot of big easter
eggs for the cosmic stuff that they're
gonna be doing during Marvel phase four
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel we're doing that giant
infinity saga box set of all the
blu-rays that's where this scene came
from all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with the big cosmic stuff
during Marvel phase 4
so we'll just break this down top-5
style starting with number 5 during
Avengers infinity war the battle on
Titan when the Avengers and the
guardians were fighting Thanos they were
gonna use this fight to show you how
Thanos is mastery of all the different
Infinity stones was evolving super
quickly they kind of reference how hard
it is to actually use the Infinity
Gauntlet from a mental perspective not
just how much collateral damage you can
soak from the energy rippling off the
gauntlet while it's being used there's a
reason why only a couple of the
characters like couple of the Avengers
and people like fan OHS are able to
actually wield the gauntlet the reason
why professor Hulk is the one to wield
the Nano gauntlet instead of Thor is
because Thor could soak the damage but
his mind isn't able to make those
fine-tuned calculations the fine-tuned
control to snap everyone back at the
exact location that they were dusted
there was also a moment when the writers
were answering all kinds of funny
specific questions about how the
Infinity Gauntlet and the snaps worked
people asked what happened to all the
people who were snapped while they were
flying thirty thousand feet in the air
on a plane
or people who are driving cars or in the
middle of doing something really
dangerous did all those people get
snapped back 30,000 feet in the air and
then just fall to the ground and splat
they said no in their minds the Hulk
knew to snap them back in a safe place
so it just takes a really powerful mind
a really smart genius level mind to do
all that all over the universe
simultaneously so throughout the battle
that's why you see fan OHS using each of
the different Infinity stones separately
with really cool powers one because it
looks cool but also to show you that
he's learning to master each of the
different stones by themselves and then
he uses a couple of them in combination
with each other showing you that he's
slowly learning to use all the Infinity
stones simultaneously which is what
happens when you actually snap someone
out of existence you're wielding all six
stones at the exact same time so during
this part of the fight scene he was
going to use the soul stone to separate
everyone from their bodies the same way
the ancient ones separated dr. strange
from his body into his astral form what
she was just trying to open his mind and
freak him out a little number for the
twist though as dr. strange tells
spider-man is that if their souls are
left untethered from their bodies for
too long they'll die
so Peter literally has to swing around
and grab their floating souls and bring
them back to their bodies this gets into
some crazy mythology comic book
territory and you can probably see why
the Russos chose to delete this scene
it almost raises more questions than it
answers like why is spider-man able to
physically touch their souls shouldn't
they just pass through physical objects
like ghosts did dr. strange lay an
enchantment on him that enables him to
physically interact with them and that's
on top of the fact that the concept of
the soul stone and its powers are never
fully explained during Avengers infinity
war or Avengers endgame you actually
have to read a lot of the tie-in
material to understand the rules that
they establish for the soul stones
powers and abilities their official
explanation is that yes obviously it can
control souls but it is also able to
preserve life after death which is why
the soul world exists within the soul
stone that orange cosmic placed the
Thanos in Iron Man in the deleted scene
go after they snapped the gauntlets the
writers in the Russos didn't call this
the soul world even though that's what
it is on the set of the movies they just
refer to it as the weigh station as in a
cosmic train station between life and
death it's exactly like the end of Harry
Potter
deathly hallows when he's in the very
cosmic looking version of platform 9 and
3/4 talking to Dumbledore spirit between
life and death
within the Marvel Universe the soul
stone captures pieces of people's souls
and keeps them there like echoes of
their souls that's how famous is able to
talk to Gamora as a child and Ironman is
able to talk to an adult version of his
daughter Morgan Stark the Iron Man scene
also kind of requires a little more
explanation because he's speaking to his
daughter kind of in the future but not
in the future like people's souls only
exist within the soul world after
they've died so at some point in the
future she died of old age and that a
piece of her soul remained here an Iron
Man is just connected to it through the
time stone the Russos also deleted that
scene of Morgan Stark in the soul world
just because people in test screenings
found it too confusing and they didn't
immediately know that that was his
daughter that he was talking to I posted
that deleted scene to my channel a while
ago so I'll link it down in the
description but number three after
spider-man brings their souls back to
their bodies mantis uses her psychic
abilities to bind their souls back to
their physical forms this is also one of
those things that seems very complicated
they don't bother to explain we've only
seen some of her powers and abilities
but if it wasn't clear from guardians of
the galaxy - mantis is also half
celestial like Peter quill she's just
another one of ego the Living Planet
many children that he sired found and
then kept around when he saw that her
psychic abilities were useful to him so
mantis is Peter Quill's half-sister they
don't explicitly let you know that
during guardians - but it's implied when
you see them have that freaky funny
PowerPoint presentation of ego doing it
with all those different species one of
them is from mantises species so she's
very powerful but neither she nor Peter
quill had their crazy God level
celestial powers anymore they only had
those and their immortality while ego
the Living Planet was still alive and
they were in proximity to him so yes
they still have celestial DNA but not
celestial powers
speaking of which will see more
Celestials during the Eternals movie
later this year so I'll talk more about
the Celestials in the MCU when they
released that trailer it'll be super
weird and super cool number two WTF
after this scene of spider-man and
mantis saving everyone there was a
deleted scene of The Living Tribunal
that's right The Living Tribunal was
actually
Avengers infinity war for a brief hot
minute well right after this dr. strange
was gonna do the same thing to Thanos
that the ancient one also did to him
right after this he was gonna send
Thanos on a cosmic tour of the
multiverse that would have ended with
him inside the super flow layer of the
multiverse to be judged by the Living
Tribunal obviously the ending of
Avengers infinity war would have been
the same so it's implied that dr.
strange would not have achieved his
intended outcome in taking Thanos to be
judged by the Living Tribunal they would
have had to explain how Thanos either
escapes judgment or defeats the Living
Tribunal which is kind of ridiculous by
itself if you're not a big comic book
reader and you don't know about Marvel's
big cosmic entities the Living Tribunal
is the most powerful guardian of the
entire multiverse and its mission is to
protect the sum total of all the
alternate realities and dimensions from
mystical imbalances when someone like
tano's threatens to tip that balance it
will lay judgment on people but it
really only gets involved in the biggest
highest order multiverse
stuff when someone is only threatening
one universe as bad as that sounds
usually there are lower order cosmic
beings that step in to deal with that
really good example is the Celestials
the Celestials are way lower on the
cosmic totem pole in terms of hierarchy
from the Living Tribunal eternity is the
only bigger and more powerful being than
the Living Tribunal but the Living
Tribunal isn't invincible there are
other Marvel characters that have
defeated it in the comics in the past
but obviously we haven't really touched
on it that much in the MCU so number one
WTF a lot of this higher level
multiverse cosmic weird stuff that was
cut out of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame they're going to be
doing during Marvel phase four the
multiverse is the next step explaining
it for all the casuals that's what's
going on with Doctor Strange two
multiverse of madness Sam Raimi welcome
back to the fold
Wanda vision the new Loki series setting
the stage for multiverse level villains
and time-travel villains like Kang the
Conqueror in higher order cosmic
entities like the Celestials during the
Eternals movie so Marvel phase four is
going to give us a much deeper version
of the cosmic super weird history of the
MCU going back to the dawn of creation
it's gonna be really cool here's my big
question for you guys let me know in the
comments what is the big cosmic stuff do
you want them
to do during Marvel phase four and
what's gonna happen in the next couple
of months is we're gonna start getting
the first Eternals trailer the first
venom two trailer more Morbius trailers
more details on what's going on with Tom
Hollands spider-man crossover of course
I'll be doing videos for all that stuff
but post your video requests and big
questions in the comments below
so everyone click here for my other big
Avengers infinity Saga deleted scenes
and click here for my brand-new
spider-man 4 announcement breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight